há exatos 19 anos
eu me formei em medicina na universidade
do porto em portugal e esse tempo todo
que eu freqüento hospitais e enfermarias
no consultório ambulatórios sempre me
impressionou muito a quantidade enorme
de doenças respiratórias que a gente vê
até hoje eu não me impressiono com a
gravidade principalmente dos casos de
asma que eu tenho tratado no cti
pediátrico
nas últimas décadas houve um aumento de
mais de 10 vezes do número de
internações de asma no mundo inteiro
e porque é isso que a gente vai tentar
conversar aqui um pouquinho hoje 10 na
época da revolução industrial houve a
nível mundial um aumento na emissão dos
poluentes e todo mundo aqui já viu
principalmente nos países asiáticos as
pessoas andando na rua com máscara e eu
não tô falando daquela epidemia de 2009
a h1n1 que as pessoas estavam com medo
se protegendo da transmissão não é isso
eles andam com máscara no dia a dia por
causa dos níveis de poluição e essa
poluição ela acaba com todo com todo o
nosso organismo ela não fumo afeta só a
parte respiratória ela dá problemas de
câncer
ela dá problemas cardiovasculares e ela
dá problemas até na nossa pele coisas
que muitas vezes a gente nem sabe
um dos efeitos da poluição na pele é
tornar a pele mais suscetível à ação dos
radicais livres e isso entre outras
coisas acelera o nosso envelhecimento ea
verdade é que todo mundo quer morrer
velho mas envelheceu ninguém quer né
mas nem tudo são notícias ruins no meio
da arte respiratória
nas últimas décadas também teve uma
queda muito grande no nível de tabagismo
e isso beneficia não só a quem fumava
nem parou de fumar mas também todos nós
que eram os fumantes passivos se
imaginem isso daqui
na década de 80
com uma parte reservada para fumantes
vamos todos estar aqui dentro fumando
junto com desenvolvimento cor das
cidades as grandes cidades
principalmente viraram grandes blocos de
concreto
a gente vê fotos aéreas de são paulo e
nova york são selva de pedra
mas a gente olhando lugares aqui no rio
de janeiro onde a gente mora em locais
que foram construídos ou reformados
recentemente com o intuito de serem
locais de entretenimento de cultura de
lazer são blocos de concreto também você
vê a cidade olímpica é árida não tem
local verde você vê a praça mauá que foi
reformada para agora para as olimpíadas
têm um museu do amanhã tenho mas são
pontos turísticos você vai com seus
filhos lá pra passear e do lado de fora
concreto em uma mesinha de grama lhe que
deve ter uma plaquinha não pise na grama
e tem meia dúzia de coqueirinho
raquíticos só pra não dizer que não
falei das flores
literalmente as crianças hoje em dia
elas não brincam mais com terra as
crianças num não plantam árvores não se
sujam na grama não brincam com animais e
se essa impermeabilização do solo que
acontece em todas as cidades
principalmente nas cidades maiores
ela leva também a gente não é preguiça
porque você vê aquele chão lisinho né
quem já foi em parques da disney agora
até nos no shopping do rio de janeiro
você tem aquele chão liso e você vê
várias pessoas se locomovendo com
carrinhos elétricos não são pessoas
somente que tem problemas de mobilidade
muitas vezes por preguiça todo mundo que
conhece a gente foi pra disney alugou o
carro ficar empurrando o filho de 8 anos
que tinha preguiça de andar
isso é um convite à preguiça se tivesse
que ficar pulando pedrinha pulando
galinho subindo em mourinho para
conseguir passar ninguém andar nos
carrinhos
a gente acaba ficando muito preguiçoso e
com o todo e se esse desenvolvimento o
acesso à água potável o acesso ao
saneamento básico ea diminuição do
número
de filhos que a gente tem hoje em dia
isso também levou um outro um outro
efeito que a hiperespecialização hoje em
dia todo mundo tem que ser muito
limpinho
todo mundo hoje tem muito tempo de
cuidar dos filhos e da banha criança tem
chão putten xampu para a hora de dormir
tem sabonete para não sei que tem um
monte de óleo vizinho
a coisa que mais ofende os pais no meu
consultório quando fala assim nossa não
conseguir ver o time porque estava com
um pouquinho de ser ainda altura
desculpe esqueci de limpar não tem que
limpar a senhora tá ali porque ela tem
que tá ali mesmo
imagina na época do gustavo que o avô
dele tinha 30 irmãos
imagina se os pais é o tempo do banho
todo mundo todo dia
duvido que vão fazer a escala segunda
quarta e sexta tomar galera nasceu ano
para terça quinta e sábado outro domingo
descanso porque não tem muito que
aguente
hoje em dia não há 11 dias e têm um
filho na nossa quase o menino villa
quase quase dá brilho na criança
baseado nas melhores campanella
você vê as doenças parasitárias nossa
gente e quando tem criança com um briga
só a criança que mesmo meio muito
desfavorecido não vê mais um briga
ok você tá dizendo agora pra gente que
tê lo deixado pelo um briga é ruim não
mais ou menos para o sistema imunológico
isso não é tão bom porque o sistema
imunológico é igual ao meu segundo filho
se você não dá alguma coisa de útil para
ele fazer
ele faz besteira sistema imunológico não
está brigando contra a lombriga ele está
causando alguma coisa pra provocar
alergia e quando a gente limpa hoje em
dia a gente não quer é dar aquela aquele
banho a avó do gustavo dava-nos nos
filhos
a gente quer é esterilizar a gente quer
fazer o genocídio das bactérias não
importa a bactéria na cabeça da criança
o sabonete mais vendido no brasil
promete erradicar 99,9 por cento das
bactérias
só que isso é suicídio porque a gente na
verdade é mais porta bactéria ambulante
do que gente nós temos mais célula de
bactéria no nosso organismo do que
células humanas
a gente está se matando o brasileiro
gosta do banho né
eu sou da europa eu posso falar mas eu
tomo banho
fui criado aqui é o brasileiro se vê uma
criança com uma pedrinha criança porque
olhando muito mais com crianças mas
adultos também serve tem uma pedrinha
está um vermelhinho tá coçando por
ressurgir banho
ano passado eu recebi uma criança de 10
meses de idade com uma doença chamada
dermatite atópica essa doença tem
costeira tem placa vermelha e tem crosta
que a mãe fazia banho oito vezes por dia
em média
só que o problema é que essa doença é
baseada justamente no ressecamento da
pele e não cada vez que a sua mãe botar
essa criança no banho ela piorava muito
a doença da criança então nem sempre a
higiene tem que ser tão exagerada e uma
outra coisa também surgiu com o
desenvolvimento foi o conforto
acho que a pior invenção por o nosso
corpo de toda toda a história foi o sofá
desgraçado vem com braço
você senta ele tinha garra
você não consegue mais sair e aí a gente
piorou um pouco mais porque alguns ser
iluminado inventou a televisão e botou
na frente dele
8 não sai mesmo quando a gente está
sentado no sofá que a gente levanta
agora nem pra trocar de canal né
antigamente era um cabo de vassoura
assim quando a televisão já era de
painel zinho a minha de seletora diana
que levantar mas depois inventaram um
controle remoto
então a gente não levanta o canal só que
quando a gente está parado há duas horas
vendo o filme a gente faz uma respiração
muito superficial
o nosso organismo está em modo de poupar
energia
a gente não faz aquele de quando a gente
tá fazendo uma atividade aeróbica a
gente faz uma respiração zinha muito
estreita
quando a gente faz uma respiração
profunda agente estica os músculos da
árvore respiratória eo músico da árvore
respiratória também tem que ser
trabalhado como qualquer outro músico
nosso corpo e naquela coisa de que nada
é tão ruim que não possa piorar quem
daqui senta na frente de uma televisão
pra ver um filme comendo um balde de
alface com cenouras baby faria aquele
pacote de batata frita a gente faz a cap
pop microondas que tem cheiro de
manteiga rançosa a gente assim top de
jack food essa junk food
além de deixar a gente obeso com todos
os problemas que vêm da e depois disso
de doenças metabólicas como diabetes de
causar disfunção cognitiva em ainda por
cima ela altera a nossa microbiota a
nossa flora intestinal começa a ser
modificada e começa a ficar com mais
bactérias ruins do que boas e como ainda
não tá tão muita gente não possa piorar
a gente usa antibiótico hoje em dia como
que se bebesse água estivesse bebendo
água de 90% dos meus pacientes que vão
numa emergência com tosse com febre
saem com uma receita de antibiótico e
aquela benzetacil nec bumbum de todo
mundo aqui conhece antigamente as
crianças de hoje em dia não conhece não
os antibióticos são cada vez mais
potentes usados em crianças cada vez
menores
todo mundo que está aqui que tem filho
menor de 10 anos conhece pelo menos mais
três marcas amoxicilina com a sigla
público todo mundo
isso acaba levando também a alteração da
microbiota e com essa alteração aumentou
também o nível de alergia alimentar
eu estou falando de alergia alimentar
para não estou falando da modinha do vou
tirar o glúten porque senão vai ficar
autista um ano a lactose porque ele
espirra muito fã de alergia raiz e essa
alergia que vem quando a gente era
criança eu não lembro de nenhum vizinho
meu que não pudesse comer o ovo que
tivesse que na festa com uma marmitinha
separada
não conheço hoje em dia o que a gente
atende no consultório de crianças com
alergia alimentar verdadeira a leite ovo
adultos com alergia a amendoim muito
mais freqüente nos estados unidos porque
a gente aqui não tenho muito hábito da
pasta de amendoim é uma quantidade
enorme de gente e essa alergia em perdão
ao contrário do que a gente acha que ela
vai dá uma coceirinha navegassem na boca
quando orban essa alergia pode atingir
níveis muito graves
ela pode chegar a um choque anafilático
que é o famoso edema de glote
aquele que mata por asfixia tem pessoas
com alergia a leite que fazem um choque
anafilático por entrar numa pizzaria
eu não falei que eles comeram a pizza
eu falei que eles entraram na pizzaria
por causa das partículas do queijo que
ficou no ar tem adolescentes que fazem
um choque anafilático porque beijaram
namorado que tinha comido algum derivado
de leite antes então isso é muito grave
e aí a gente bagunça nossa flora
intestinal toda aquela comida porcaria
que a gente
o nih a gente toma antibiótico espécie
bebendo água e detona a nossa flora
intestinal a gente faz o que o
probiótico industrializado todas as
formas e feitios tamanhos tem de bebê
tem de diluir
eu já vem prontinho para tomar banho de
comprimidinho tem de mastigar
mas será que a gente precisa mesmo usar
só probióticos industrializar a troca
não tem nada de natural que a gente
possa fazer pelo nosso organismo para
melhorar essa flora tem em vários
alimentos eu coloquei aqui há alguns
deles azeitona alho faz parte da nossa
dieta normal trocar a comida refinada
por alimentos integrais grande bico que
não é tão freqüente entre nós muito mais
freqüente na comida árabe
os vegetais em picles são boas fontes de
probióticos para os chocólatras o cacau
também é mas não é aquele ao leite
quanto mais escuro melhor temas
frutinhas aquelas frutinhas vermelhas
que a gente só comprar no natal época é
muito caro pra comer o ano inteiro
mirtilos framboesas amoras
mas tem também a comida brasil raiz de
mamão banana semente de abóbora pêra
maçã vários alimentos que ou eles nos
dão o probiótico ou eles não nos dão
algum nutriente algo a fibra que melhora
ao crescimento das bactérias boas a
gente não precisa e leite fermentado
esquecido famoso leite fermentado não
posso falar o nome para fazer propaganda
então assim de tudo que a gente
conversou aqui vocês vêem que não tem um
único motivo uma única causa para o
crescimento da alergia é multifatorial a
gente morar mais de dentro de casa do
que acontece na a gente passar mais
dentro de casa do que o tempo que a
gente passa fora acaba a gente até muito
mais contato com os alérgenos indoor que
são que os ácaros fungos
nem o cemitério de animais domésticos
barata
a alteração da nossa microbiota porque a
gente acabou de falar a poluição do ar
ou b
idade muitas coisas isso não quer dizer
que o desenvolvimento seja ruim
desenvolvimento é necessário ele faz
parte a gente vai ter que ser virtual
que a gente não pode fazer é ficar refém
das facilidades que esse desenvolvimento
nos dá a gente não pode é ficar seguindo
o fluxo como se não tivesse nada pra
fazer
a gente vive numa sociedade paradoxal
que nem cachorro correndo atrás do
próprio rabo
a gente come porcaria depois toma
probiótico a gente tem controle remoto
até levantar a cortina mas depois a
academia
a gente faz preparo pra correr a
maratona para postar aquela foto maneira
no nas redes sociais
mas se tiver que mandar dois quarteirões
até o trabalho a gente chama um táxi
há uma estimativa de 40% da população
mundial portadora de alergia
quando você tem um filho
se o pai ou a mãe é alérgico essa
criança tem um risco de 40 por cento
disse tornar alérgica
se os dois forem 80%
daqui a uns 30 anos a população mundial
vai ser uns 10 milhões de pessoas
quanto vai ser o percentual de alérgicos
daqui a uns anos
o que a gente está disposto a fazer para
mudar isso
o que você está disposto a fazer o que
eu trago para vocês aqui é um convite
vamos dar um passo para trás
vamos voltar um pouco mais para a
natureza
vamos deixar as crianças se sujarem
vamos ter mais cascas do que a embalagem
no lixo de casa
[Aplausos]